was this a surprise good morning tom I
think it was the timing maybe a little
bit of a surprise and I would say maybe
even a little bit of surprise internally
because you think about a press release
that was you know issued at six o'clock
last night it feels like it was sudden
but I don't think ultimately that
anybody is really scratching their head
I mean it's hard for a company to put up
pretty to use an earlier to more than
results for as long as McDonald's has
and not you know start to have sincerity
I'm at the top there's front of the
store back of the store like Walgreens
is about the front of the store and then
there's the pharmacy in the back of the
store Easterbrook is considered a front
counter guy what does that mean and how
will mr. Easterbrook change the game
yeah I think you know what we're talking
about is really kind of engaging with
the customer again and getting
McDonald's you know in really improving
the way people think about McDonald's
you know when they come into the store
what they see when they walk in who they
see when they walk in how they think
about the menu so it's less about the
operations in the back and the back of
the house it's much more about you know
customer engagement and I think you know
probably all agree that McDonald's could
use a little bit of burnishing of its
reputation with customers Sarah there
are two ways to look at this one is that
McDonald's has a system the system
cannot be changed the other
interpretations comes from Susan
Berfield she's running in Bloomberg
business
yesterday she wrote there was one thing
that customers really wanted for
McDonald's all-day breakfast Thomson
said he was considering it that was in
April 2013 so Ken McDonald's not be
changed or did Don Thompson do a bad job
of changing it I think there's probably
a third a third right here which is that
McDonald's can be changed here we've
seen it before you know now going on
twelve years ago the last time
McDonald's was really felt like it was
it was kind of wandering in the desert
but it's you know it's a big ship and it
can be very hard to steer I think it's
very safe
say that you know the world around
McDonald's changed a lot faster than
McDonald's did in the last couple of
years Sarah what what does it Easter
book Easterbrook have to do to turn
McDonald's around to get the share price
moving oh that's you know that's that's
a great question you know and if I knew
for sure I'd be the successor not Steve
Easterbrook but I think you know what
we've seen is you know McDonald's has an
old category obviously is losing some
ground to fast casual but you know
McDonald's and other restaurants like
McDonald's still have a place there so
people who want cheap food you know that
tastes good and that's and it's served
quickly and McDonald's me to convince
customers that they do that better than
anybody
I was actually thunderstruck by the
Board of Directors I mean every company
has a different character this is an
eclectic group of Chicago people Andy
McKenna legendary in Chicago John Rogers
of course of Ariel investment in Miles
white of Abbott Labs is this a narrow in
bread board Susan Arnold Peter record
formerly with Mattel is this a narrow in
bread board that's been caught asunder
after a 20-year free ride I don't think
yes it's certainly a long tenured board
and sometimes that can that can lead to
complacency and I think you know that
may be an issue I'm it's also the case
McDonald's has always been a culture
that's very I don't say insular you know
and in some extent has really served it
well people who work there love
McDonald's you know they eat sleep and
breathe McDonald's and continuity has
been McDonald friends more than once but
but I think you know it is it is
possible that in another company with a
different board we might have seen
change happen more quickly there senator
thank you so much with Sanford burns